like any watching cave only at breakfast
80 people managed have died from the
coronavirus in China with nearly 3000
others infected joining me is dr. Yvonne
Doyle medical director and director for
health protection for public health
England hello to you thanks for joining
us do we have a plan to track the 2,000
or so people who actually arrived from
Wuhan recently how do we do that well
okay what we've been doing since we
spotted that this could be a big problem
is intensifying our work on this in a
number of settings including in airports
and so when it became clear that direct
flights were coming through regularly
not just from ohan but from other parts
of China where there could be infections
we've been ready with a team of doctors
to meet those who meet our criteria
really for if they may be ill with
something that needs further
investigation and of course that the
case definition the kind of criteria for
that are that somebody has a fever a
cough difficulty breathing and has been
connected with Wuhan in the past 14 days
now the people who you're describing
here and we are now looking back to see
whether any of them are still in the
country because some of them will have
returned to China but there are there
are moves to identify them not always
possible to find everybody but we're
working to our best endeavors the
problem is though doctor I mean I was in
Helsinki yesterday there were flights
coming in from Beijing and Tokyo and
other parts of the Far East
those off the flights were wearing their
masks one wonders how it affected those
masks are but it's not just Wuhan
anymore so it's very quickly able to
spread this virus and the fact that it
has an incubation period of a couple of
weeks so you don't even know people had
it until the perhaps they've left the
country well we're learning a lot about
the virus I want to say we're well
prepared okay so as I say since we
spotted this in the early New Year
ourselves we've been intensifying our
work across government but also at the
NHS because our view is actually
although airports seem important the
most likely place that we may find the
case is someone who's in the country
already and it's absolutely critical
that
Public Health Service and the NHS are
ready to both diagnose that and then to
designate the person to the right
facilities now we've set all that up and
I think I want your viewers to be
reassured that we and the NHS are ready
for that that's the most likely scenario
we're dealing with we don't know where
all these people are they're doing it's
impossible to know where they are in the
country whether they're even still here
we make our best endeavours to do just
that but as I say people will have
returned of course within the 14 days
they may have been here for short
periods but to come back to airports
although we have a lot of work going on
with the air for the main airports where
this is relevant the most likely
situation if we get a case is that the
person is in the country what about
these masks i touched on that are they
in any way effective when masks are very
important in hospitals and they
particularly in ITU and the intensive
side but whether they're in any
relevance out on the street because
people forget how to use them properly
what's much more important is that
people are aware of personal hygiene
hand washing and the catch had been it
kill it back to the old public health
outage that you know if your state is
probably a respiratory virus so droplet
infection important use a tissue
throw it away wash your hands that's
actually more effective yeah and I was
it don't touch metal because metal the
bugs can live longer on metal than
anywhere else is that just a no wives
tale or no yes I mean people will be a
weary of what they touch but actually
the important thing is it's droplets and
hands yes so keep keep your hands clean
I'll just wash them so okay I'm guessing
though you know to all intents and
purposes we will have some cases of the
corona virus and here in the UK already
I would expect so and that's the coming
back to the point that that's the
scenario we have been preparing for that
we are ready don't assume because this
is a virus that we can diagnose it
immediately
our scientists actually have developed a
screening for viruses that will detect
this the one of the first countries in
the world that are able to do that
that's hugely reassuring and the tests
are being transmitted through a
particular lab that has that expertise
once you've diagnosed it then we have a
path for how to deal with it so that
patients
are dealt with in the most effective way
and you're not alarmed that it's
probably here already I think with
infections k health is global and we've
been here before you know we had to deal
with this middle-eastern virus we've
dealt with SARS we deal with flu
regularly which can be very alarming as
well and very very dangerous so we're
ready we've got a very good invention
service okay doctors good to talk to you
thanks very much indeed for a kiss thank
you